Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two. David P.
This is a belated 16th anniversary.
Congratulation from The Eggman.
Let's take a quick listen. Very nice message.
Speaker 7: Hey, Dave. I had rural northern Indiana
on my bingo board, so. Oh, I just won again. Hey,
listen, man, I missed you while you were gone,
so congratulations on six. Seventy six years. It's
been a long time. You know, I've listened for like
fourteen of those. I've been leaving messages for
like almost fourteen. I wanted to tell you that
Jesse Moore was great while you were gone. I'm
now listening to his show as it comes out. Oh,
yeah. I always love barrackers. So he's also
awesome. Those guys are great. I missed you.
I'm glad you're back. I'm glad you're
healthy. That's all. Happy anniversary.
It's been a hell of a ride between politics one
day with your brother in the mom's basement solo.
Speaker 1: Yes. Now, that's an exaggeration. We
used to joke that we were broadcasting from my
mom's basement. We never really were. I was like
30 at the time. I had my own place. OK, but I
appreciate the sentiment from the Eggman. We've
got a great bonus show for you today. It turns
out the results of the Arizona audit are getting
delayed because a bunch of the people involved in
the audit are sick with covid not a big surprise.
Also, Alex Jones may be turning on Donald Trump,
saying maybe he's a dumb ass. We'll talk about
that. And then lastly, for a very brief period,
solar power did surpass coal power in
Australia. And we will talk about the
significance of that and much more. All of those
stories on the bonus show sign up at goingback.